[Music]
44 seconds of two logos this opening
credit helicopter has no idea where it
wants to go beauty pageants I had no
idea of breasts for so haha Freddie
Prinze jr. but that's sexist comment is
about your future wife and the mother of
your children
yo chumby take a high do I sin the
cliche asshole or come baby let's beam
down to Dawson's pubes huh
movies writer makes a reference to his
own show here's this like scratching
sound scratching sound why are you even
telling the story if everyone's heard it
already he's been decapitated the blood
I realized this correcting the story is
probably some kind of misguided
commentary on the ever-evolving nature
of urban legends but for the movie it's
just a noise man no he wasn't
decapitated
he was gutted so literally all four of
you have heard the story enough times to
be sure your version is correct
that's the original story that's the way
it really happened also a movie that
famously deviated way way far from its
source material has a character who
believes in telling the story correctly
Ryan Philippi and Sarah Michelle Gellar
are sexually involved but are not also
step-siblings in this movie are you sure
this relationship is defined jacket
removal as the universal sign for being
ready for sex camera pans away from what
we actually want to see to give us the
view of the dirty ass ocean
they gave Ryan Philippi a script that
said whatever your line is just be a
dick about it
these are some useless ass flashlights
here since the entire scene is shot with
extraordinary lighting Thank You Steph
well then let's definitely build the
entire movie upon this one half-assed
statement that no face is all messed up
but you definitely be able to figure out
who this random person was if his face
wasn't messed up doctor you don't make
that decision pretty much any of you
could make that decision by oh I don't
know checking for a pulse about what he
was crossing the road in the middle of
the night okay it was an accident you
weren't drinking or speeding let's go
make so much sense I'm surprised this
movie allowed her to say that line of
dialogue movie expects us to believe
that the guy in the truck can't see ray
and Barry moving a fucking body smacks
first off Helen seems to believe that
everyone else in this movie knows who
everyone else is by pure sight second
off one person ends up driving by on
this lonely road and it just happens to
be the guy who's in unrequited love with
Julie can I do for you max you can work
that much
stank grin off your face of all the
people for him to have class warfare
with he picks the really poor kid it was
mostly just as downtrodden as he is
these kids convinced they committed
manslaughter who have carried the body
to a secret water dock thing have still
not check the dudes pulse just because I
have something integral to the plot on
my head right now guy who was just
fighting back fine decides to descend
into the water completely still his hand
extended up showing off the evidence he
grabbed of his killers identities like
he's the lady of the flake movie now
expects us to believe that berry can see
perfectly in this water when it's dark
outside and there's some mega beam of
light able to penetrate the surface to
light it up like word in Finding Nemo or
some movie waste the killer won't die
scene in the first 25 minutes of the
movie but it sure ain't done anger both
Julie's boyfriend and best friend
allowed this to happen I think that just
lost my girlfriend over a murder face
Julie you're going home for the summer
good think Julie's were looking to go
there else we never could have heard
this clunky exposition remember son I'm
fine
is it racist that she's gonna dump this
black girlfriend for Brandi in like a
year I think it's racist I helped my
friend stash a dead body eating which
despite you having killed someone a year
ago I only just now noticed I was kind
of weirded out it didn't have a stamp a
return address on it but it's probably
just like any other letter really to
tell that guy you killed man she's
really not that bad when she's not
hiding murdered people in the water roll
credits
Julie believes two things that are
unbelievable
one that her mom would in any way know
who delivered this letter like the
person who sent this would show his or
her face and two that her mom won't in
any way be curious as to the contents of
the letter didn't keep looking at it but
it's only seven words long for the title
of a movie sure but short for a letter
pretty strong wind indicates something
ominous from exactly one year ago is
about to resurface cliche Helen doesn't
have any argument if you need to speak
with her I suggest you go to women's
fragrances ten feet to your left it's
almost like the scene was created so
that the movie could cast suspicions on
the hot girl from Billy Madison and I
don't care that girl from Billy Madison
did not do this because she's way too
pretty for this we were so careful oh
you were not what are you doing here
- let your renowned sense of humor cheer
us up this is nothing I know what you
did last summer
oh what a crock of shit you're right
I'm sure all the other residents of this
sleepy fishing village also got the same
note it's just
prank except you did kill a dude last
summer so maybe there's that a relief
snacks without even once addressing the
letter or anything because that's what
dickheads do is care so much about
something to threaten your life over it
but not actually address what it is max
grabs the hook berry threatened him with
because if it's one thing this movie
needs it's to make everyone a suspect
it's not like he wasn't already the most
obvious don't you test me mother
quarterback ass ooh
exposition via angry nerd shouting
that's every bit as original as it is
stupid as hell I'll be damned
I'll be down to imagine this guy just
showing up out of nowhere at this very
moment so raise you up to be a fisherman
huh that's racist you managed to find
berry drive to this dock wait for him to
beat up Max and still somehow I've been
used up your lunch hour alright I'll
just
angrily slam this here in case people
haven't gotten the point yet killer
kills max because after all he's
definitely not innocent in this caper he
drove through the crime scene without
knowing there was a dead body or being
involved with his death so that guy also
was this the plan come out to Max's work
take a hook and use that as your primary
murder weapon and kill him first by all
means because reasons and send Julie a
letter but no one else because she's
special and everyone else is not hello
do you care you're gonna public gym and
you're an asshole with no friends so
what's this hello anyway and didn't
Kevin Williamson make fun of this very
thing in scream killer always looks for
the light that can cause scary shadows
classic horror movie bulk appear he
walks the entirety of the locker room
which is all three rows and yet somehow
doesn't hear his locker being open ten
feet away
there he is a starting quarterback of
the Prometheus school of running away
from things football team there's simply
no place to avoid a car anywhere killer
believes he will survive this way of
trying to murder people also Barry
survived this
Oh movie fades to plant because the
killer doesn't killed Mary here even the
movie has a hard time figuring out the
point that's right the killer left him
alive because the proper way to exact
revenge on people is to put them for no
reason for an inordinate amount of time
duh he wanted me dead he could have done
it he's just come with us who is Helen
we're going to have to remove your
character soon for asking this damn
question too many times
besides What did he say at the very
beginning of the scene no for the 40th
King time I couldn't see his face
some Diana slicker narrows it down
little fishing village dude who says
he's trying to narrow it down
Helen asked him a question and he
doesn't know a lot of details so it's
not like he expects anyone to know who
it is based on what little he knows
who's ever doing this isn't going to the
police we could find this guy talk to
him wait a minute the whole reason you
think you can do this is because the guy
could have killed Barry but chose not to
but did everybody forget when he smashed
him through a shaft with his car a
minute ago what's that not an attempt on
his life
did the killer even know he'd survived
that this article about the Marlins is
about the Houston Comets WMD 18 this
article about the Marlins is about Steve
Spurrier being a dick to Tennessee
football also you live in the time of
dial-up modems and brick laptops but
sure instant connection to library
database huh three lesbian Anne Heche of
course David Egan sister has a rain
slicker hung up prominently in the
living room because everybody did it
Missy stands around like none of this is
suspicious at all it's a series of Anne
Heche non-reaction shots in the editing
room they look for whatever look meant
the least they were sweet on each other
for about two minutes
these people are total strangers but I
guess I can go ahead open up and tell
them about this friend David and some
semi private details they didn't ask for
because this is something people do run
like a madman to a car because someone
forgot their cigarettes and by the way
we've never seen any of these characters
smoke the entire movie yeah it's funny I
don't see it I won't bother to let you
stand back from my car as I Drive off
killers been waiting for Helen all day
and luckily she doesn't lock the door
and has an alcoholic father who's
wrapped up in college baseball killer
makes a casual stroll at the stairs
confident that Helen won't see him in
time
the nothing happens jumpscared I am NOT
in this closet right now yeah because
that's what sisters do you just walk
into the other sister's room without
saying a damn word and putting a hand on
the shoulder because they apparently
know they're in a horror movie what the
fuck is up with this killer he is crazy
patient to basically tell people what
they already know he knows what they did
last summer and the killing should have
begun long ago especially since he
decided to kill max out of nowhere hell
what was the point of taking the hook
out earlier the whole plan was to just
send a message also this asshole was
able to walk out of the closet cut her
hair put a crown on her head write a
message on her mirror and walk back down
the stairs and out of the house without
making one bit of noise not soon enough
for me when did this motherfucker have
time to do this you can't spend all
night plotting a bad haircut in Helens
room and then decide you know what I'm
gonna put a dead body and Julie's trunk
and cover it with crabs without making a
single noise
it appears that Julianne hill and got in
their sexiest outfits to go
investigating oh you this dude would
have had to follow Julie to this point
clean out the trunk with a dead body and
hundreds of crabs in broad daylight but
the body and crabs in his car and drive
off with nobody seeing it I believe yeah
but this is exactly what he wants we
can't go to the police not now he's
Kitty character does exactly what I did
in the theater when I watch this movie
also what is he waiting for movie run
time I love how he's so angry he waited
the year for some reason and then just
wants to Jack ask these kids instead of
kill them Mary decides out of the blue
to think Ray is behind this with no
evidence beyond his own frustrated
forensic impotence then let's get the
hell out of here we can leave town
disappear I've already disappeared but
then you came back home allowing the
killer to find and taunt you you offer
no evidence that disappearing is not an
awesome plan because it is you were told
the previous night that the parade was
the next day and that she couldn't go to
work at 10:00 a.m. because of it so how
did she get manageable hair in time for
the parade remember how ray was being
sarcastic about everyone in town wearing
a rain slicker and how it'd be hard to
find the killer with that kind of
description yeah well these guys don't
give a shit rain slicker you're fuckin
guilty I don't know better tackle all
the people with rain slickers and find
out
just because a person is weird does not
mean they are a walking jump-scare
Factory so many people to tackle so
little time oh I just realized the
killer is a fisherman and I live in
fisherman central I don't think berry
can tackle that high left is no I hidden
from the insurance company because they
wouldn't pay me the money I know if it
was suicide
I still have it because suicide notes
are wonderful keepsakes this town's
pageant forces the previous year's
winner to sit on stage for every single
act because if there's anything this
town loves more than fish its
awkwardness plus we didn't see the
previous Queen at all in the beginning
of the movie excuse me coming through
don't mind me oh there little lady
you're screaming for obviously no reason
whatsoever
we'll have to restrain you because of
what I conclude to be your period hey
what's the problem well if anyone would
simply look upward toward the balcony
this would be an easy mystery to solve
this is really not my idea of a funny
joke
I guess all blood was wiped from the
scene in the amount of time everyone
restrained Helen because she's a woman
Helen plays the pronoun game so that the
already angry cop will have to ask who
he is I'm taking home parents really
worried about your found there's only
drinking a fifth of what he usually does
and he's switched from college baseball
to Kerley absolutely nobody is around on
July 4th because the killer wants it
that way I'm gonna have to take the
alley because there's a yellow thing in
the small town Road that I is one of the
few cops here know nothing about plus
the alley is where death happens there's
been a murder and you're gonna fry in
hell if you ignore it didn't you
participate in a murder last year
what kind of frying do you expect to be
doing dickhead killer knew that not only
would this difficult can't be driving
her home but that he'd also drive right
through this alley because he'd easily
fall for the fake town road closure cops
would totally know about charade
actually he's right in front of him
dumbass now you're responsible for
killing another person yeah you don't
want to kill people with a bloody hook
you don't want people thinking you're an
unsanitary killer she's been running and
he's been walking this whole time she
that runs really slow or he walks really
fast
also buffy is somehow able to run all
over town without anyone but the killer
seeing her or anybody even being outside
movie unintentionally inspires Elsa
based sister issues from frozen killer
is certain that he will retell him
before her sister opens the door to the
store so he keep walking because this
doesn't work he'll surely be inside the
store somehow in the next scene
Elsa might be one of the most
infuriating characters in horror movie
history which says a lot she eats her
sister's so much that genuine pleas for
help outside don't even get her to do
the right thing also if you're Helen at
what point do you finally say okay I
need to run I feel really sorry for
Bridget Wilson like I feel like I have
to apologize for this movie and I didn't
have anything to do with it that's how
bad this character is and yet killer
knows that the other entrance was open
and managed to make it inside before it
got locked because that's what stores do
on July 4 is just have back entrances
open well into the night girl calling
9-1-1 her to scream so naturally she
hangs up on 911 l did this asshole
dispose of Elsa and get underneath one
of these plastic covers so fast this guy
walks when he kills people but he's like
the flash when it comes to setting stuff
that doesn't make any sense this is why
most horror villains choose not to use
the cover yourself in plastic first
method of attacking victims so the
platform got away boohoo
just cut the freaking pull cord she's
using you idiot they are clearly shown
in this shot to extend all the way down
to where you're standing and that is
maybe one of the most convenient piles
of trash ever how had the fireworks not
gone off already it's been dark for
hours what do you care get into public
view already
Helen sake did he not only get here
ahead of her to hide and pop out but
also know exactly which route she was
gonna take look I know you wanted a shot
with both marching band people and the
killer in it so we see how close she got
before dying but these chords are
marching on the damn sidewalk and no
parade in any small town I've ever been
to does that because usually usually
there are spectators watching the parade
standing on the sidewalk Jesus also I
just realized didn't they do a parade in
the daytime for the pageant and now a
nighttime parade in a tiny fishing
village let's don't love parades
wait a second do you think this Willis
guy killed David then we killed him I
know it's a bunch of bullshit the guy
knew David Egan was gonna mourn his
girlfriend's death and showed up to the
exact spot to kill him and it gives you
guys a morally justified pass for
killing Willis because he was an evil
hook killer the whole time on the boat
inside part witch boat this is a
freaking boat yard raise one of the guys
you're trying to revenge murder and you
just knock him out she's already running
to your boat
stab him really quick come on man you
really suck at revenge this picture was
taken a few hours ago he then got a
super large print made at the one hour
photo lab and came by
here to tape it up on the wall even
though he's been pretty busy killing
Barry and Buffy and all kids like you
should be out having fun drinking party
this guy decides for no reason then he's
going to pretend to be a good guy before
he kills Julie they could just kill her
now but he knows the drama can't be
built that way
jump in the water just stomp on her
fingers yeah probably the perfect time
to call now for Julie now while you have
an unkillable killer on the ropes
don't bother disarming that dude before
you call out to your ex-girlfriend damn
it man did you forget that you're in a
battle with a hook killer also again the
killer merely incapacitate srei instead
of killing him easily it's kind of like
he forgot ray is one of the four people
he's intent on revenge murdering killer
decides I could kill him with my hook
but I'll let the ocean decide this yeah
okay so how did he drag Helens body all
the way to his boat from the alley where
he killed her without anyone seeing it
so many things in this movie depend on
the whole town being unobserved isn't it
like mega convenient that this heavy
hook on a rope is the perfect distance
from the fulcrum above to be grabbable
by Ray but also face smashing distance
for the killer who is 20 feet below ray
wait did I say convenient I'm an
impossible that's not how pendulums work
you've dicks my daughter got wrongfully
killed power just hook him in the
stomach when you leave a man with it
make sure he's really just irony Wow
glad that's over
there's no way he could survive drowning
a second time on the anniversary of the
first time he drowned we never killed
anyone I know it was killing me and
because that man wasn't dead and was
actually a killer I feel no guilt
whatsoever because of that extremely
lucky circumstance I love you Julie no
one gets me the way you do knowing what
I know of both your characters which is
nothing I think that's a true statement
may induce Danny on this line both party
invitation has the exact same
handwriting as the psycho killer who
sent her a note last year role Creole
will have to wait around another year
for that bull can't hardly wait oh well
my guess it's a dream no sequel she dies
sequel dream so that's how that works
I must have been a dog
[Music]
his name was David Egan in Project
Mayhem we have no names no you listen to
me this is a man and he has a name and
it's Robert Paulson
kichaka he loved this jacket you were my
kid brother you would have killed for
this jacket soaked lining fine
Corinthian leather
get a bad taste in my mouth out here
aluminum ash I can smell a psycho steer
I got an idea let's make the car a place
of silent reflection from now on okay
[Music]
I'll give you something you've been
obsessing about ever since our parents
got married be more specific in English
off your brains out no way you can put
it any way